Hollywood mats Trump postures about
sexual harassment and generally noise
everybody who doesn't live in Hollywood
will talk about it I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay so this is the show that we do
after the Oscars where everybody on the
Left gets super annoyed after all the
virtue signaling and all the politics of
last night and all the politics that
Hollywood routinely shoves in the faces
of Americans if you respond to that it's
considered bad taste find that it was
pretty stacked politically from the left
never mind that was openly acknowledged
by the people on the stage if you
respond to that then you see you're
being triggered if you respond to that
if you point out that it's political if
you point out that Hollywood is pushing
a particular political agenda this makes
you the bad guy we'll talk about all of
that in just a second but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
Birch gold so today again the stock
market starts off and it is down we've
been down for a week we've been down for
the last month the stock market always
has some baked in volatility it doesn't
mean you should invest in the stock
market but it does mean that you should
hedge some of your betting with
investment in precious metals and that's
why I talked to my folks over at Birch
gold group they sell physical precious
metal for your own possession and they
will ship metals right to your front
door right now thanks to a little-known
IRS tax law you can even move your IRA
or eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver it's perfect
for people who want to ensure that their
hard-earned retirement savings are
protected from inflation or stock market
ups and downs they have a long standing
track record of continued success Birch
gold has thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews
and right now when you contact Birch
gold group you can request for free and
information can on physical precious
metals they give you these comprehensive
16-page kit showing how gold and silver
can protect your savings how you can
legally move your IRA or 401k out of
risky stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA so get your no-cost
no-obligation kit go to birchgold.com
slash bent birchgold.com slash ben and
again ask all your questions make sure
that you feel perfectly comfortable and
once you do bert school those are the
people that I trust to invest in
precious metals birchgold.com slash Ben
check it out again birchgold.com slash
banner okay so as I say one of my great
irritations in life is this game that is
played by folks in Hollywood in the
entertainment community where they make
a bunch of content and they do it with
politics explicitly in mind and then if
you respond to that then it's you who
are being oversensitive so if you say
that the shape of water aka grinding
Nemo a movie in which a woman has sex
with a fish but only after she is helped
by a communist a gay guy and a black
woman and she herself is
mute she helps a fish escape to her
bathtub or she has sex with it if you
say this may have some left leanings if
you say this may have some political
messages then yours how dare you
mentioned that it is a great piece
of art how dare you who do you think you
are right it doesn't matter the people
who have worked on the movie say it's
political doesn't matter that critics
have said it's political doesn't matter
that viewers know it's political because
it's obviously political if you point
out that it's political no how dare you
call it sjw splash you're oversensitive
you're ruining the art just terrible if
you mentioned they call me by your name
which won a Best Original Screenplay
louder Best Adapted Screenplay last
night if you mentioned that's a story
about a 24 year old dude seducing a 17
year old dude which means that the dude
who he's seducing is underage and if you
made that movie about a man and a woman
this would now be part of the me2
movement or if you mentioned that if
that guy who is 24 was named Kevin
Spacey he'd be banned from Hollywood for
doing that in real life no how dare you
it's a beautiful love story that has no
political agenda at all none no
political agenda if you mentioned that
there are a slate of movies last night
there were mediocre at best but were
praised to the skies because of the
intersectionality of the people who made
them so for example Lady Bird met just a
man movie it's a as Sonny bunch puts it
correctly it is a long ish episode of
Roseanne right that if you say that if
you point out that Greta Gerwig movie is
like a it's not the worst movie ever but
it's not the best movie ever that's
because you must hate women if you don't
pay attention to if you think the Black
Panther was like a good action movie
like a nice good action flick but it
wasn't the most important movie of all
time
you are politicizing it not the New York
Times or Trent a thousand pieces of a
thousand thing pieces about how was the
most important movie ever right if you
say it may not be the most important
movie ever then you are the problem in
your trigger listen here's the deal
folks I'm not angry about any of this
I'm not upset about any of this I'm just
pointing out the hypocrisy of people who
overtly state that they are acting in
political fashion then the minute you
say well you know I'm not really fond of
politics being shoved in my face they go
I'll clown nose on no we're just we're
just your jesters we're just your
entertainers we're just here to
entertain so what really ripped the
masks off last night is Jimmy Kimmel
made a joke in the middle of the Oscars
first of all of course Jimmy Kimmel was
asked back because now he is his guy
Benson puts it the Pope of Hollywood he
is the secular Pope and Jimmy Kimmel who
somehow
elevated himself from staring at boobs
on the man show and asking women to find
out what's in his crotch with their
faces legitimately right we have stay
he's moved on from that to being the me
to anti-gun Pro Obamacare spokesperson
for the left say he was asked last night
to do his routine and his routine was
predictably not funny in the slightest
so here's my honest here's my honest
take on the Oscars I did not watch one
minute of this live and I was much
happier for it I watched the highlights
later okay so I'm taking some of this on
faith that he wasn't good last night I'm
taking that from the critics and the
ratings which were abysmal I'm taking it
also from seeing clips of him because
they're not funny I can't overall give
you like every minute of the Oscars I
didn't watch every minute because I have
a happy life and there's no reason why I
like most Americans should have to
suffer through this garbage but any case
Jimmy Kimmel rips the mask off of what
Hollywood has been saying for years but
it's so funny when Hollywood says things
were more allowed to take it seriously
but if we say it in the conservative
movement then we're bad we're terrible
so here's what Jimmy Kimmel said last
night of the nine Best Picture nominees
only two of them made more than a
hundred million dollars but that's not
the point
we don't make films like call me by your
name for money we make them too upset
Mike Pence okay and the reason that gets
a big laugh is because it's true
it's because it's true some people are
saying well you think the author of call
me by your name it's a joke you think
the author of call me by your name was
really thinking of Mike Pence not on the
news thing that Mike Pence specifically
but I'm sure that the author of call me
by your name was thinking I'm making a
very significant film because it's
important that Americans see that
homosexual love stories are just as real
and intense as heterosexual love stories
I promise you that that was going
through his head because of course it
was going through his head you wouldn't
expect anything else to go through the
guy's head doesn't mean there's anything
wrong with him doesn't mean there's
anything wrong with his motive but to
suggest there's no political motive at
all is still he know when I did my book
primetime propaganda in 2011 I went and
I spoke to dozens a hundred people who
are like the top craters in Hollywood
the people created friends the people
who created soap the people who created
Golden Girls the people who created
America's Funniest Home Videos like
legitimately every show that was a top
show from the 1950s all the way forward
to the 2000s I interviewed somebody from
that show and the message that I got
from virtually everyone is of course we
put our politics in our films of course
we put our politics in our in our TV
shows would you expect us to do any
differently and the answer was no I
don't
Specht you to do anything differently
but the great lie that they hid behind
was well we put our politics in there
not because we are propagandists no no
no no no we put our politics in there
because it's what the audience demands
when we make a show like friends and we
have a lesbian wedding first season or
when in the later seasons
Ross and Rachel have a baby out of
wedlock and they're in love with each
other but we don't let them get married
because that would be too conventional
when we do all of that that's just
because the audience wants to hear that
perspective it's something the audience
wants here and look the ratings prove it
and we're the ratings for friends good
yes they were but Kimball points out the
truth here the truth is Hollywood would
make that stuff no matter what because
people in Hollywood want to feel good
about themselves it's so funny people
talk about the DC cocktail parties talk
about the DC cocktail circuit they talk
about how all these people in DC want to
get together and go to these shishi
parties where they hang out that
actually happens in Hollywood Kate talk
to anyone who's worked in Hollywood
these cocktail parties they're not as
common in DC they are really really
really common in Hollywood everybody in
Hollywood goes to cocktail parties this
is how they get jobs and one of the ways
they get jobs is by talking to each
other about how they virtues signaled
this year they talked to each other
about what kind of difference they're
making for the world just like the the
ridiculous
fictional creators of Google in in
Silicon Valley they go out they go
around talking about how they're going
to make the world better through better
compression algorithms and this is what
they do they go around talk about how
their film really made a difference in
lives this is how they think because if
they really thought that they were
around to just make movies and people
clubbing each other with sticks and that
we all laugh and enjoy them because hey
we all like movies they wouldn't feel
very fulfilled yeah there's a movie
called Sullivan's Travels from the 1940s
a great movie and the whole movie is
about this guy who wants to make
comedies he's a he's a comic writer and
he makes comedies these very famous
comedies and then he decides he wants to
make his deep film because he feels
unfulfilled he feels like he hasn't made
his contribution to the art and so he
goes out on the road as a homeless guy
and he experiences all sorts of
craziness and suffering all this
terrible stuff happens so when he comes
back and he realizes he ends up in a
chain gang and he realized and all they
showed these guys comedies at night some
of his comedies and he realizes that's
me doing something for the world
that's something Hollywood folks do not
understand okay they don't want to make
their comedies they don't want to just
do what it is that we enjoy them doing
they don't want to make thor ragnarok
they want to make homie by your name
they may make Thor
rocks that they can pay the bills but
they actually want to make is call me by
your name is when Jimmy Kimmel says when
he reveals their then what they're
actually doing is making films
specifically designed so that they can
feel good about themselves that it makes
them feel good to slap Mike Pence makes
them feel good to slap people in the
middle of the country that is true
now when Jimmy Kimmel says it we can all
take it seriously but if I say it then
it's because I'm politicizing the issue
I remember we did the exact same thing
with regard to for example Joe Biden so
back in the early 1990s there was a show
called Murphy Brown Murphy Brown had
Cameron what was the name of the woman
Candice Bergen playing the lead when
Candice Bergen had a baby out of wedlock
and Dan Quayle said this is not good for
the country it is better if you have
mothers and fathers having babies on TV
right this is propaganda from the left
and Dan Quayle was ripped up in town it
was his Murphy Brown moment how dare he
suggests that this was politics it
wasn't politics it was just TV it was
just TV and then Joe Biden came out in
the in the mid-2000s right right after
or the late 2008 2009 he came out and he
was talking about Murphy Brown he was
talking about Will and Grace and he said
of course TV has changed minds without
Will and Grace when people have been so
accepting of same-sex marriage and the
answer of course is no propaganda has an
effect that effect is to propagandize
that's the intended goal and so when
Jimmy Kimmel says that they put profit
aside to make some stuff like call me by
your name or the shape of water this is
true does that mean it's deeply wrong
and deeply to know they can do whatever
they want it's a free country that's
fine but me acknowledging that their
political is no different than them
acknowledging that they are political
and that profits well important to make
sure that they boost their industry
their business is no different from my
business the difference is I'm honest
about it I am here to push a certain
political point of view to push
principles that I think are important
I'm not doing it just to respond to the
market in fact I take pride in the fact
that we at the daily ware don't just
respond to the market it's why we make
certain editorial decisions right so why
we don't show the names and faces of
mass shooters I'm sure that hurts us in
the click count but that is something we
are willing to do right well we'll only
take a hit and I'm honest about the hits
that we are willing to take for
particular political view it's why I
never fell on to the Trump train and the
to the extent that I was you know
talking about everything being Magne
Magne Magne genius oh I'm sure I would
have made more money if I'd done that
because there are certain principles I
think are important the difference is
Hollywood has principles it thinks are
important but they lie about it they
won't tell you that they will say that
they
just there to make entertaining content
and the politics are secondary utterly
untrue
not true Kimmel makes that suggestion
Kimmel is correct okay what Kimmel says
here is right and you have to keep that
in the back of your mind when you watch
the rest of the Oscars because what the
Oscars really are about are not just a
moment for Hollywood to award the best
filmmakers and to show you what's best
in film it's not about that at all what
Hollywood's Academy Awards are really
about is what Kimmel is saying it is
about the slap it is about making people
in the middle of the country feel
morally less it is about the suggestion
that Hollywood is showing the best of
itself it's Hollywood's book report at
the end of the year where they
demonstrate why they should be there and
according to Hollywood the reason they
should be there is not because they
entertain us not because they make
movies who want to watch but because
they do important things and so they
have to reward important movies you can
see Hollywood's shifting standards for
itself over the course of Oscar history
and I'll explain that in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at movement so the best
watches on the market today movement
watches they used to be just a
crowdfunded source working out of a
living room in the past year they've
introduced a ton of new watch
collections for men and women they've
extended it to sunglasses
fashion-forward bracelets okay all of
their watches are clean they're
beautifully designed they are really
they're really durable you know my son
loves the watches runs around with them
smashes them against the wall they're
all as good as new
and they look terrific I've worn them to
Congress I've worn them to the White
House I've worn them to to a bunch of
different places because that's how nice
they are and you're getting these things
for like 95 bucks
okay the movement will watch a star just
95 dollars in a department store you're
looking at 400 to 500 dollars and that's
how these watches are really classical
looking they're really nice and they
make a really affordable gift for men or
women my wife has one I got one for her
my mom has one got one for her my dad
has one so everyone in my family has
movement watches and there's a reason
for that right now you get a special
deal to go to MVM t.com slash appear oh
you got 15% off today MVM t.com slash
capiro 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns go to MVM t.com slash
capiro and join the movement again
movement watches are top of the line you
will really enjoy them go to MVM t.com
slash appear that lets them know that we
say you and get 15% off your order with
free shipping and free returns check it
out all righty so one of the reasons
that you can see that Hollywood has
shifted
view of itself is the change in in the
demographic of the people who actually
watch Oscar films so it used to be that
Oscar films between 1983 and 2000 2003
really virtually every Oscar film was a
major winner in terms of the box-office
virtually every Oscar film was eating
really well at the box-office at least
the the film's the won Best Picture
right and so I'm gonna look up the list
right now and I will tell you there has
not been an actual good movie that is
won Best Picture at the Oscars like a
great movie that's won best pictures at
the Oscars in my opinion since 2010 and
there hasn't been a box office winner at
the Oscars for nearly 15 years for
nearly 15 years it's really an amazing
amazing thing I mean let's let's look
back at the at the Best Picture winners
so 2016 the best winter picture was the
Best Picture winner it was moonlight
which made like 5 bucks at the box
office
before that it was spotlight fine movie
completely forgettable you know again I
enjoyed spotlight I think moonlight is a
fine film it was obviously the social
justice winter because it was about gay
black people in the inner city whatever
that's fine but that's not exactly
designed to be a box office busting
winter ok spotlight one the one the year
before that the year before that it was
Birdman which I thought it was just an
ex Korbel film I just thought was an
awful awful movie 12 years of slave
which i think is a very good movie but
not obviously one that's gonna bust down
the box off his doors but it's it's
about slavery it is not a highly
entertaining film I think it's a well
made film I don't think it's as well
made as for example shown there's less
but 12 years of slaves a good movie but
is it like an all-time classic movie
probably not Argo which is completely
forgettable now do you even remember our
ago I remember when it won like I saw it
it's fine it's fun but it's not like
it's an Argo is not an important movie
the artists right and none of these
movies made more than $5 a box office
the King's Speech was the last really
great movie that I think was was a big
winner but the Oscars The Hurt Locker
was the year before that Slumdog
Millionaire which did decently
at the box office but won over like The
Dark Knight are you kidding me okay are
you kidding me
it hasn't even that was 2008 okay it's
been 10 years does anyone even watch
Slumdog Millionaire now it's a fine film
I mean I enjoyed it but it's not the
Dark Knight okay No Country for Old Men
is 2007 that was the last big box off
Twitter that actually did really really
well at the Oscars was no country
romance that's 2007 and before that was
the departed which may take crash the
worst movie of all time hey Million
Dollar Baby again okay but sorry movies
about euthanasia don't exactly blow it
up at the box office though and then you
get a goodbye but by 2003 I think was
really in the bush here this happened
2003 by the middle of the Bush era you
can see the shift for Hollywood the
shift goes from we are here to make
movies that Entertain You - we are here
to make movies that are specifically
designed to say something say something
important because before 2003 all of the
movies that were winning or big box
office winners the reason this is
important is the people in Hollywood the
people who vote at the Academy Awards
see their role differently they see
their role in life seriously as we are
here in order to in order not to make
big movies and make lots of money and
earn us all enormous paychecks
that's something nice that we do but
we're really her to do is push the
message and you can see that from the
Oscar winners because before that it was
lord of the Rings Return of the King
it was gladiator it was Shakespeare in
Love which did really well was Titanic
it was Braveheart
it was Forrest Gump it was Schindler's
List and Unforgiven it was Silence of
the Lambs
it was Dances with Wolves right every
other year it was in top five to top ten
box office movie that was winning and we
haven't had one of those in like 15
years okay there's a reason for that and
it's because Hollywood does have
messages it wants to promote so we're
gonna talk about some of the messages
that they wanted to promote at the
Oscars last night okay so here let's
start with this and I think this says it
all last night Emma Watson showed up to
the Oscars with a new tattoo her new
tattoo said on it time's up there was
only one problem with her tattoo it did
not have an apostrophe so she actually
just has something that says time's up
which doesn't even know what that means
without the apostrophes so you know no
Regatta no regards for emma watson on
her tattoo but this was the theme of the
Oscars last night the theme of the
Oscars last night were men were bad men
generally are bad but here's the thing
Hollywood knows that men are bad and
they're good about this they they get it
they get men are bad particularly white
men white men are really bad white men
are terrible and the way that we know
that white men are terrible is because
Hollywood on the one hand is pushing
diversity last night meeting diversity
of skit not not viewpoint diversity of
skin color diversity of
gender but when it came to men you know
men bad men those people there's bad
they're bad people here's Jimmy Kimmel
last night saying what we really need in
America is more men without penises
thankfully Hollywood is there to provide
them in an ample supply here is Jimmy
Kimmel Oscar is the most beloved and
respected man in Hollywood and there's a
very good reason why just look at him
keeps his hands where you can see them
never says a rude word and most
importantly no penis at all he is
literally a statue of limitations
[Applause]
the kind of men we need more of in this
town that's right well we need more of
is not virtuous men not men who stand up
for women not men who use their
aggression in positive ways not men who
get married and have kids not men who
use their penis properly now that would
be too limiting what we need is men
without penises now it's really funny CS
Lewis once wrote a entire essay called
men without chests and his entire essay
is about when you have a civilization of
men who have been scooped that their
value has been scooped out when they've
been give nothing to live for they
become a problem they become problems
men without trust in one of the great
essays in all of Western literature okay
and the entire premise is when you
remove masculinity from men you are
doing them damage and you are turning
them into hoaxes of themselves into
husks of themselves and here you have a
guy on stage at one of the most watched
event of the year talking about how it'd
be great if men had no penises it would
just be fantastic now I know we're
supposed to it's just comedy just good
but then the whole point of comedy is
that there's a an element of truth to it
is there not this is what we've been
told for years so if Hollywood says that
men at the very end of the show by the
way Jimmy Kimmel reiterated this like at
the very end of the show Kimmel actually
suggested that that he wishes that he
were a woman which I don't know what the
limitation on him is I mean what one
thing that we have learned is that if
you wish to be a woman don't let anyone
stand in the way our dreams man you can
be a woman if Jimmy Kimmel wants to be a
woman he can make this happen if he
really admires men without then he
presumably can actually go and and take
care of business I mean this is this is
something we can it's a free country but
again like this is the message that how
they wants to promote like this is what
Hollywood actually wants to push it's an
amazing thing okay so that was it that
was the main message and so how they
would take this on because the truth is
that the big problem in Hollywood of
course has been aggressive men who have
not had any moral limitations put on
them who scorned the fundamental
institutions of Western civilization
like marriage and chivalry they scorn
these things and then they have used
their power positions in order to
victimize women so how did Hollywood
deal with that last night did they face
up to it did they face up to it of
course they didn't face up to it so here
is the this was I think the key there
are three Weinstein accusers three
accusers of Harvey Weinstein got up and
they were pushing The Times up movement
so this is Selma Hayek
Anabella ero and Ashley Judd okay all
three of them have accusations to make
about Harvey Weinstein now Annabella ero
was apparently blacklisted by Weinstein
Ashley Judd says that Weinstein abused
her and salma hayek called one Cena
monster in the New York Times now I know
all of that because I actually
researched this stuff if you watched the
show last night you wouldn't know any of
that you just see three beautiful women
on stage making extraordinarily vague
references about something bad that
happened in Hollywood we can't mention
its name we can't talk about what
happened we can say things like time's
up or we can say me too but those are
buzzwords we're not we don't actually
know what happened like if you were just
a bit alien and you came and watched the
Oscars last night well you would assume
is that Hollywood was rewarding itself
for how it treats women not castigating
itself for how it treats women because
watch this okay watch the vague
references as Jim Garrity and National
Review says this is all fortune cookie
stuff listen what they actually have to
say there's not one mention of sexual
abuse sexual assault or sexual
misconduct anywhere in this clip it's an
amazing amazing thing and then they
followed up this clip with a montage
talking about how wonderful Hollywood is
to women and black people and Indian
Americans and the vast panorama of
colors the cinema scope of Hollywood
I'll get to all of that in a second I'll
show you this clip because it really is
an amazing thing how Hollywood end it
around the biggest scandal to hit
Hollywood in the last 50 years okay but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at stamps.com so
stamps.com
is the easiest way to access all of the
amazing services of the post office it
never closes you can print postage for
letters or packages at your own
convenience 24/7 the exact amounts of
postage every time you never under pay
or over pay again we use it here at
Daily wire so that our employees don't
have to run over to the post office we
save money we make sure that we're not
wasting time again that's what stamps
calm is for it is convenient it is easy
is reliable and it is efficient so check
it out right now again they make it easy
they'll send you a digital scale so it
automatically calculates exact postage
they'll even help you decide the best
class of mail based on your needs you
don't have to lease an expensive postage
meter or anything right now you can
enjoy stamps calm with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and the digital scale go to
stamps calm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro that stamps calm and you want to
use promo code Shapiro you get a four
week trial plus postage and a digital
scale all of this you get
you'll offer again stamps comment for
promo code Shapiro and start using it
you'll save yourself lots of time and
lots of money all those great services
the post office provides made convenient
for you right there on your desk
stamps calm promo code Shapiro check it
out okay so again back to the me to
moment in at the Oscars so here are
these three women all of whom were
victimized by Harvey Weinstein
apparently and you never get one mention
of this not one okay here's the thing to
say it's an honor to be here tonight
this year many spoke their truth and the
journey ahead is long but slowly a new
path has emerged the changes we are
witnessing are being driven by the
powerful sound of new voices of
different voices of our voices joining
together in a mighty chorus that is
finally saying times up ok do you have
any idea what they're talking about
like really I mean if you just came in
from the street then you had no idea
what was going on in Hollywood you
hadn't read into the headlines has any
of the research would you recognize any
of these three women except you might
say okay there's a lady from double
jeopardy and there's the lady from from
that movie about Frida Kahlo right leg
legitimately that's that's that's all
you would see is just these people
making really vague references to the
diversity of voices and then they follow
up this diversity of voice stuff with a
montage and is the montage about women
who have been abused in Hollywood is
montage about taking responsibility for
that abuse see here's the thing that
Hollywood did last night they had Jimmy
Kimmel get on stage and talk about how
all men all over the world are
responsible for evil against women so to
everyone else's fault
maybe that includes Hollywood but it
really is everyone's fault because it's
penises that are to blame of course
penises they're the worst except in fact
if there's a movie that wins Best
Picture or Best Adapted Screenplay about
a twenty four-year-old men having sex
with a 17 year old man then penises are
not the worst men penises are great but
penises are the worst when it comes to
like male treatment of women male
treatment of other men you know
treatment of underage men particularly
not a big deal unless Kevin Spacey but
if you find out this confusing we can
clear all this up for you because we
have a montage last night over at the
Oscars and the montage was all about how
Hollywood it turns out is a welcoming
place and now it turns out that they've
turned the corner in Hollywood you see
before they even knew they had a problem
they had the cure and the cure was
interest
allottee what we needed was more people
making movies based on identity so that
they could have a more diverse viewpoint
or something and somehow this is going
to cure the problem of men abusing women
in Hollywood by the way if you think any
of this stuff is gonna have a long
lasting impact on Hollywood you got to
be joking
cuz gonna have five seconds of impact
the media will move on
within two years men will be back to
abusing women exactly the way they did
before in Hollywood because Hollywood
has no moral standards I know I've lived
here my entire life okay here's the
montage last night in which Hollywood
which should be doing penance right they
should be doing Mayacamas instead
they're they're exploding that they are
actually our moral betters
I haven't raped anyone you haven't raped
anyone you haven't sexually harassed or
abused anyone you haven't made movies
about people you've sexually harassed or
abused but it's really Hollywood that
has to tell you a thing or two
so here's Hollywood explaining its
mission in life this entire fall the
meet who the time's up movements
everyone is getting a voice to express
something that has been happening
forever
not only in Hollywood but in every walk
of life they posit that for one second
sorry that okay so number one that Mira
Sorvino was abused by Harvey Weinstein
did she say anything about that there no
she didn't know if you were watching
that you'd have no idea what she's
talking about continue some of our best
work has come from turmoil we have been
in denial about the things at work some
of my favorite movies are movies by
straight white dudes about straight
white dudes now straight white dudes can
watch movie starring me and you relate
to that it's not that hard I've done it
my whole life okay pause it right there
and then there's the cheer right there's
the cheer for the guy from the big sick
and from Silicon Valley directed by the
way--by
created by Mike judge with straight
white man so there there he is
and that's the thing right now Hollywood
is gonna Pat itself on the back because
look look at all these new creators were
bringing to the floor now some of these
movies are actually good right the big
sick is a pretty good movie um Greta
Gerwig movies not particularly good but
it got all sorts of plaudits the big six
is a better movie than Greta Gerwig
movie by a fairly long shot but there's
Greta Gerwig talking about
yeah the she directed Lady Bird it's an
amazing film how do we know because
she's a woman and this is the way we
work now right we have to know that only
a woman can direct Batgirl right Joss
Whedon can direct Batgirl only a woman
can direct Batgirl and only a black
person can direct Black Panther and OH
presumably a transgender person can
direct a movie about a transgender
person and that's how we know if the
movies good not whether it's good or not
but because Hollywood is providing all
sorts of representation right
representation we're not to be moral but
as long as we have intersectional
representation that is truly what
matters so remember this montage started
with them talking about me to remember
all the way back like a minute and a
half ago when they were talking about me
too
does anything here have to do with me
too does anything here have to do with
time's up not a thing
not one thing zero things have to do
with me to our time's up that this is
the way that Hollywood elides its own
moral culpability in one of the great
scandals of late 20th and early 21st
centuries and then suggests that they're
actually winning because Kumail Nanjiani
used to have to watch movies by white
guys and identify with the characters
like listen I'm happy to identify with
characters who are not of my race I've
said this all my life I'm Jewish I've
identified with characters who are not
of my race my entire life we're not of
my religion my entire life did it ever
bother me one iota no and do I think
that like it's deeply important than now
people identify with an Indian guy or a
Pakistani guy cuz I think the non johnny
is Pakistani no I don't think that that
matters a lot either I mean if the
movies good two movies good I don't care
but apparently that's not the way
Hollywood is supposed to work anymore we
know that Hollywood is good because
Hollywood is making movies with diverse
people whether or not the movies are
good so you can continue with this with
this montage demonstrating how much
better Hollywood the people of Hollywood
are than you are as a human
Thelma Louise came out oh wow Helmut
Louise was terrible movie by the way
changes everything we're gonna see so
many more movies starring female
characters that didn't happen but this
isn't now that moment okay we can stop
that okay right there okay so then the
idea now is we're gonna get a lot of
movies starring female characters and
now we're finally gonna get more movies
like Delma and Louise god forbid we
should get more movies like Feldman
Louise one of the worst movies ever made
I'm fine with female characters in
starring roles Wonder Woman I thought
was a very good movie last year and guy
like gal gadot so that's great um but
again how about quality movies I saw a
study in The New York Times there's
really funny saying how many of the Best
Picture winners percentage of lines read
by men versus percentage of lines read
by women they neglect to mention the
fact that the one that won last night
was about a woman who is mute okay it's
sort of hard to make that calculation
when the woman in the movie is mute how
about minutes of screen time that's a
much better gauge of whether it's a male
centric movie or a female centric movie
then number of lines spoken by women
there are a lot of great performances by
women in which the acting is is not in
the lines okay we're gonna get to
Hollywood being better than you in just
a second their continued push for the
notion that while they are in fact some
of the least morally responsible actors
in America there actually are great
moral leaders by the way you want to
know why Trump won is why Trump won okay
when you have a bunch of people from
Hollywood lecturing you about how they
are the great moral leaders well making
some of the least morally responsible
films of all time and being very
irresponsible in their own personal
lives then yeah that's no one's gonna
listen to you when you say the Lena
Dunham should be our shining a star of
morality okay we're gonna get to more of
this in just a second but for that
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
we're calm over its daily we're calm for
$9.99 a month you can get the rest of
this show live you get the rest of the
Andrew Klavan show live the rest of the
Michael Noel's show live
you'd be part of our mailbag we're gonna
be doing another episode of the
conversation you can ask me questions
there all of those things you get when
you are a subscriber plus you got this
the very greatest of all beverage
vessels leftist ears hot or cold tumblr
you will enjoy it you'll live with it
you will love it it will confer upon you
great benefits of which I cannot speak
but once you have it you know so go
check it out annual subscription ninety
nine dollars which is cheaper than
monthly subscriptions you just want to
listen later go over to iTunes
SoundCloud YouTube please subscribe
please leave us a review we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
already so let's talk a little bit more
about the the virtual signaling over the
Oscars and how ridiculous it was so my
favorite point to this was the part this
is a thing they're doing now where
Hollywood stars meet the commoners they
did this last year where they brought a
bunch of people into the Kodak Theatre
in the middle of the Oscars and they did
it again this year with a bunch of
people who are starring in these movies
that none of these people have ever seen
right they're all there to see a wrinkle
in time which is a kids movie which
actually might make some money at the
box office but all these Oscar nominees
who no one's heard of walk into the walk
into the theater and start interacting
with the audience oh don't you see
celebrities they're just like you
they're just like you okay someone who
took in the I think in the last week and
a half I probably took 2,500 pictures of
people and just people who are fans of
the show and enjoy there's nothing
special about celebrities in fact
celebrities are some of the most empty
people that you will ever meet depending
on what it is that they do for a living
but this sort of we're here to hobnob
with the common folks with the hoi
polloi before we go back to our shining
star shining beautiful palatial estates
on the hill and never see any of you
again it really is kind of galling so
here they aren't walking into the midst
of the commoners and demonstrating to
the commoners that they too are regular
people before they go off with their
million-dollar salaries and their
special sports cars with their beautiful
lovers here they are last night
[Applause]
so army hammer is literally firing hot
dogs into the crowd this is what we have
become right these are our betters
firing literally food into the crowd I
mean if there was ever a more symbolic
Marie Antoinette let them eat cake
moment than this firing hot dogs into a
crowd of commoners ha ha we shall feed
the commoners with these hot dogs from
our giant hot dog gun and then they
lecture us it's just unbelievable my
favorite thing last night about the
lecture was it was the so Kobe Bryant
who settled out of court on a sexual
assault case right he won an Oscar last
night because there was a short film
that was made out of his out of his
retirement letter about dreams of
basketball or whatnot he won an Oscar
last night which means the Kobe Bryant
has now won as many Oscars as Gary
Oldman which is really ridiculous
so Kobe Bryant gets up there he wins an
Oscar on me tonight after settling out
of court several many years back with a
woman who accused her of raping her in
in a in a room in Colorado here is Kobe
Bryant dunking a Laura Ingram in the
crowd cheering whatever form your dream
may take it's through passion and
perseverance that the impossible is
possible I don't know if it's possible
I'm a basketball player is really
suppose to shut up and dribble but I'm
glad I'm glad we do
more than merit okay there is ripping
laura ingraham because we're supposed to
shut up in dribble ha ha ha ha but it's
so funny the entire crowd is totally
fine with Kobe Bryant a guy who settled
out of court on sexual assault charges
you know doing this doing this routine
so just just amazing these are our moral
betters you can tell that what what
Holly wants push again the Oscars are
not about Hollywood demonstrating its
best it's about them teman straining
what they think is best about themselves
to you
that is what Holly was about so there is
a song that was performed last night
from the movie Marshall about called
stand up for something and I guess it
was common and Andra day who are
performing this song and I guess it's
mostly like sort of a beat poetry about
politics don't know the date so we stay
awake me we take for sake
[Music]
tattoos where hey you don't keep my feet
because it's great when they don't load
we stayed in the height I love the
women's rights
[Applause]
[Music]
okay they stand for peace love and
women's rights don't you understand when
they go low we go high but we kneel for
the anthem and the president leads with
hey yeah the no politicking here but if
a back wave again if I comment on
politics it's my fault you watch the
headlines after this show will be
Shapiro rips into Oscars because he's
bitter about yet I didn't watch it man
okay like do what you want to do but I'm
pointing out that the culture gap in
this country the the cultural betters
who did they wonder in Hollywood why we
don't take them seriously on politics
they wonder in Hollywood why there are
so many people in the middle of the
country who find Hollywood distasteful
they wonder in the middle of the country
and they wonder in Hollywood why it is
that people in the middle of the country
are only going to see their big bunch of
pictures and not any of their artsy
films
maybe it's because you're constantly
lecturing everybody in the middle of the
country about how you're better than
they are and then the minute that you
say listen we don't like being lectured
they go hey we're just artists man
we're just artists you don't get to be
propagandists and admit that you're
propagandists and openly propagandize
and then pretend that you're just there
for the art of it hade them work that
way
that's not the way that it works you can
use messaging in your art but that is
messaging in your art and you don't get
to have it both ways this clown nose on
clown nose off routine is really
irritating I think the greatest contrast
here by the way is coming in Andra day
do this thing about we're gonna kneel
for the anthem gary oldman wins an Oscar
he thanks America and listen to how the
crowd responds I owe this and so much
more to so many I have I've lived in
America for the longest time and I am
deeply grateful to her for the loves and
the friendships I have made and the many
the many wonderful gifts it has given me
my my home my livelihood my family I
know Oscar music thanks America he
talked about how Great America is dead
silence dead silence and all but big
applause for Francis McDormand of course
Francis McDormand wins Best Actress for
what I thought was actually an
overwrought performance in three
billboards I liked three billboards I
thought the movie was fine I thought the
best thing in it was Woody Harrelson
he's the only one who didn't win an
Oscar Sam Rockwell the guy who you'll
remember from Iron Man 2 won an Oscar
and so did Francis McDormand the woman
you'll remember from Fargo she won an
Oscar too
she got up at the end and she did a
whole Women's women in movies routine
because you know if there's somebody
who's really been victimized in the
movie industry its Frances McDormand
who's now winning her second Oscar and
who's been working continuously for
legitimately 25 years
here's Frances McDormand pushing
inclusion riders she said this is the
end of her speech and nobody knows what
she's talking about but I will explain
because we all have stories to tell and
projects we need finance don't talk to
us about it at the parties tonight God
invite us into your office in a couple
days or you can come DARS whichever
suits you best and we'll tell you all
about them I have two words to leave
with you tonight
ladies and gentlemen inclusion Rider
okay nobody knows what she's talking
about an inclusion rider is a rider in
contract that states that there must be
parity with the number of women
employees or black employees we have to
have an intersectional contract listen
she's happy if Frances McDorman wants to
do that that's fine that's fine but
Hollywood ain't gonna operate on
inclusion riders because the reality is
that Hollywood still needs to make a
profit the sad truth of Hollywood is
that none of the movies that won last
night make Hollywood work nobody watched
the Oscars last night because it's three
billboards people watch the Oscars
because of thor ragnarok because that's
how people engage with Hollywood people
engage with Hollywood because a Black
Panther and Thor Ragnarok and Wonder
Woman and the reason they're not
engaging with more serious content is
because nobody in Hollywood will make
more serious content that is not replete
with nasty messages about traditional
values or Hollywood or Hollywood
superiority to the rest of mankind the
minute you make a serious Hollywood film
that doesn't involve those things that
thing will do blockbuster at the box
office but they won't do any of that
they separate it into stuff that makes
money and stuff that we have a message
with and so long as they do that then
all the stuff that they honor at the
Oscars is the stuff nobody'll watch and
the stuff that actually makes it work is
gonna be all the money floats stuff
through Marvel or DC that's that's how
this is gonna work okay so I want to
move on from the Oscars and talk a
little bit about president Trump's
tariffs plan so the president has now
come out and says that it's time for a
change on tariff policy here is what he
tweeted out he tweeted out that quote we
are on the losing side of almost all
trade deals our friends and enemies have
taken advantage of the US for many years
our steel and aluminum industries are
dead sorry it's time for a change make
America great again ok so again as I
explained last week tariffs
stupid steel and aluminum industries are
not dead and the stock market continues
to drop because the president doesn't
know what he's talking about when it
comes to these tariffs so the stock
market dropped immediately on opening
about a hundred points it is now up
about 185 points
it'll probably drop again it's very
up-and-down right now because of the
volatility in the stock market it's
unclear what Trump is actually going to
do on all of this it is true that Trump
has promised this for a long time so
Wilbur Ross the the Commerce Secretary
who is most famous for falling asleep
and drooling during meetings he came out
over the week and he said no one should
have been shocked by the tariff talk
which of course is true almost a year
ago he commissioned the Commerce
Department to do the studies on steel
and aluminum they've been through any
number of interagency reviews before
they were released to the public so with
the whole year of preparation I don't
know why anybody should have been so
shocked okay so he's right that nobody
should have been shocked about this the
only thing is that we were told that we
shouldn't have to really pay attention
to stuff that Trump was saying we should
just pay attention to what he was doing
if what he said during the campaign is
what he does now I'm going to be much
less happy with his governance than I
have been for the last several months
speaking of which you know the media are
making a big deal out of President Trump
over the weekend he did an event and he
praised China's president for life the
president basically of China is the
dictator of China because voting ain't a
thing over there is now the president
for life he's basically appointed
himself to an endless term and CNN got
hold of audio of Trump talking about
this there's one thing from says that's
disturbing and one thing the media is
blowing wildly out of proportion
she's a great gentleman he's now
president so we cut out some of the
laughter therefore for time purposes but
the reality is the people are laughing
all the way through when Trump says that
he wants to give being president of for
life a shot one day he's obviously
joking he's obviously responding to the
crowd that's the media latched on to it
they should have latched on to is the
president talking about how great how a
wonderful human being and how great
Xiao Jing ping is the the president of
China he is a communist dictator who
repressed this his own people and leaves
millions of people in suffering no he's
not a great guy no he's not done a lot
of great things and when the president
praises the the president of China that
way that is not a positive the president
should not be doing that that's where
people should really be directing their
ire not at the stupid line about
president for life and no he said that
he thought that it was great that the
president of trying to had declared
himself president for life and that part
he was serious and that's absurd of
course you shouldn't have American
leaders praising dictators that's just
bad policy now speaking of bad policy so
all of these kids from from Parkland are
still going around doing a lot of media
appearances a couple of these kids
Cameron kaske and I think this is David
hog these are two of the kids you've
seen the most they were on with Bill
Maher over the weekend when they said
some of the most obnoxious things ever
if the goal here is to earn your way
into America's hearts so that we pay
attention to you I'm gonna rights this
is not the way to do it sincerely I
really do to all of the generations
before us we sincerely accept your
apology and we appreciate that you are
willing to let us rebuild the world that
you've dug okay so that is the most
obnoxious thing so you what is that
generation done by the way like kids who
are 17 and what a Millennials done like
my generation I guess they the formerly
labeled Millennials people born between
81 and 96 hey what have we actually done
for the world like the Millennials the
answer is not a whole hell of a lot I
mean I think the baby boomers were
pretty disastrous but at least they gave
us the civil rights movement and the
women's rights movement yeah well what
what exactly have had Millennials done
for the world not much at all right the
arrogance of somebody saying we want the
previous generation should apologize to
us guess what world the world didn't
start with you okay the previous
generation
you live in the freest most prosperous
country in the history of the world and
previous generations have to apologize
to you if you were born five hundred
years ago you've been born into abject
poverty by any global modern standard
but you know we're supposed to pretend
that these kids have been done some sort
of essential wrong not just by an evil
shooter which of course they were but by
an entire society of people who have
done wrong to them an entire all
previous generations have not lived up
to them come on come on guys this is
just it's it's bad it's bad politics
it's bad press and it's and it's dumb
it's just it's not smart and again it
just tears America apart for no apparent
reason which is I guess we're all now in
the business of doing this when we do it
the Oscars and what we do on is what we
do whenever there's a tragedy to which
we all to which we all of which we all
mourn and we all have to tear each other
apart it's just the thing that we're
into okay time for some things I like
and some things I hate and then we'll
get to a federalist paper so things I
like so something from Hollywood that I
actually enjoy made by a bunch of people
who are on the left but it's a very
enjoyable show is to show the good place
if you haven't seen this show it's very
clever the entire premise of it is
basically what woman dies and she goes
to what is supposed to be heaven but it
turns out that on earth she was actually
kind of a bad person Kristen Bell's
character and so she's accidentally
ended up in heaven and she's trying to
hide that from everybody because she's
actually a bad person and and the show
is really good actually gets better as
time goes on so the first episodes are
good the first couple episodes are
really good it slows down for three or
four and then it gets a lot better you
can go watch it in Netflix it's really
worth watching and especially when the
emissaries from Hell come it gets very
very funny so check this out this is a
good place
you Eleanor shall strop our deck cool
three glasses of wine and no hangover
this rule these people might be good but
are they really that much better than me
did you fill your bra with shrimp no yes
so who's right every religion guest
about 5% except for Doug Forsythe one
night he got high on mushrooms and got
like 92 percent correct this shows
really buddy what was funny about the
show actually means it starts off as
this very second low left version what
happened is right everybody goes to
heaven regardless of what they sort of
did on earth as long as they didn't take
their shoes and their socks off on an
airline flight then they then they go to
heaven and then it moves into some more
interesting and convoluted moral
questions like it's it's a show that
makes it will actually drop references
to Plato and cons in the middle of the
show which is really fun so check that
out okay that's the thing that Hollywood
is producing that how it produces a lot
of stuff that I like it's what makes me
so upset when they pretend that they are
not propagandists for particular
viewpoints particularly in their
showcase the Oscars okay time for
another thing that I like so Bill Maher
did something great last night
or on Friday night rather he was talking
about the fake news drama and he says
that everybody is is focusing on fake
news because there is a lot of fake news
out there namely this perpetual outrage
machine that seems to be dominating no
wonder fake news resonates so much with
Trump fans because so much of it is fake
just nonsense made to keep you
perpetually offended with an endless
stream of controversies that aren't
controversial and outrageous that aren't
outrageous because places like The
Huffington Post and BuzzFeed and salon
they make their money by how many clicks
they get yes the people who see
themselves as morally superior are
actually ignoring their sacred job of
informing citizens of what's important
and instead sowing division for their
own selfish ends all power does have
bill maher all kudos to Bill Maher that
is exactly right the manufactured
outrages of the day are
just that they are stupid they are
outrages that mean nothing and Maura is
exactly right about this and the left
traffic's in them okay time for a quick
thing that I hate so I could've devote
the entire show two things I hate
actually if I if I had so choose it I
could have just called it Oscars I hate
but instead I will I will reserve one
clip for Jordan Klepper over on Comedy
Central so speaking of Hollywood bias
there's not one right wing or even
remotely right wing comedian on Comedy
Central like there's no one I'm even
mildly to the right tendencies if you
are slightly to the right of Karl Marx
you do not belong on Comedy Central's
Jordan Klepper has a new show on Comedy
Central which of course means he should
be on CNN and speaking about politics
because being a comedian means you
should talk about politics unless you're
a comedian on the right of course so
here's Jordan Klepper on CNN talking
about how it is time for America to get
serious about guns
I went through the process of what it
would take for a good guy with a gun to
stop a bad guy with a gun I talked to
people on both sides of the Dickey
amendment and the argument with funding
the CDC and quickly realized that in
America there is so much more common
ground and it was really frustrating
because then that wasn't the narrative
that was getting out into the public and
so I did a special that was focusing on
that correct somebody who comes from
Michigan I have a lot of gun folks in my
my family and and in my surroundings
many people that own guns and want to
ensure that there isn't gun control well
yeah I think like we're guns means
something different than what they mean
in New York I say we're hunting is an
issue right and so I for me I felt like
I was so frustrated because I got to
talk to people who who had guns people
who didn't have guns and saw that there
was there was a different narrative here
that wasn't that wasn't being covered
and okay so there's Jordan Klepper from
Comedy Central talking about how no one
takes the gun debate very seriously
because the small minority has loud
voice etcetera etc etc again Comedy
Central not exactly an unbalanced and
unbiased source okay quick description
Federalist 18 thankfully it's relatively
it's it's a Federalist paper that is
replete with historical riri telling so
there's not a lot to say about it
it basically it's by Hamilton and
Madison it's a continuation of why the
Articles of Confederation are a failure
in it Hamilton Madison give the example
of the failure of the Grecian Republic's
to avoid war with with one another he
talks about how they talk about how the
Grecian republics were basically
constantly a war with one another
because the Confederate system
which they lived did not have a strong
enough central government and they write
even in the midst of defensive and
dangerous Wars with Persia and Macedon
the members never acted in concert and
war more fewer of them eternally the
dupes or hireling zuv the common enemy
the intervals of foreign war were filled
up by domestic vicissitudes convulsions
and carnage and so the suggestion is a
stronger centralized government will
prevent the states from reaching out to
foreign governments to form alliances
with them against other states this of
course has historically been true during
the Civil War the the South actually
reached out to Great Britain in an
attempt to make an alliance with Great
Britain any war like that is going to is
going to entail States reaching out to
foreign sources and unending eternal
discord inside the country itself ok we
will be back here tomorrow with much
more i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018